I said to do you mind if I just speak
frankly to you said sure I said look the
thing you've lacked this year and it may
be you just don't have this valve so be
honest with me but you you've lacked
empathy you haven't been comforter in
Chief you don't seem to have that tool
in your Armory you just want to be the
strong commander-in-chief and I said
that lack of empathy is going to cost
you because you're up against Joe Biden
who everybody knows from his own
personal tragedies has huge amounts of
personal empathy for people and it would
go an awful long way but then I watched
him go out the next day and do some
press thing and he was just exactly the
same as normal so I don't think he
really has an empathy valve well he's
capitalized on being disagreeable if
you're in the public eye like that and
you're a Critic and you want to say what
you have to say and you want to separate
the wheat from the chaff it's useful to
be disagreeable but you can't be
disagreeable all the time it does look
to me like this is an Achilles heel for
Trump this tendency to devolve into a
very effective but somewhat juvenile
bullying and then combined with that
this proclivity to play the victim which
I really think is stunningly off brand
for him it leaves everyone on the
conservative side in the same position
that the radicals on the left want to
put conservatives which is to abandon
all Faith In The credibility of
institutions
[Music]
designed for anyone to sell anywhere
Shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big
businesses an all-in-one e-commerce
platform Shopify makes it simple to sell
to anyone from anywhere whether you're
selling succulents or stilettos start
selling with Shopify and join the
platform simplifying Commerce for
millions of businesses worldwide with
Shopify you'll customize your online
store to your brand discover new
customers and build the relationships
that will keep them coming back Shopify
covers all the sales channels to
successfully grow your business from an
in-person POS system to an all-in-one
e-commerce platform even across social
media platforms like Tick Tock Facebook
and Instagram thanks to 24 7 support and
free on-demand business courses Shopify
is here to help you succeed every step
of the way it's how every minute new
sellers around the world make their
first sale with Shopify and you can too
go to shopify.com jbp for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire Suite of features start selling
on Shopify today go to shopify.com jbp
right now that's shopify.com jbp
hello everyone I'm very pleased today to
have
with me Mr Pierce Morgan
Mr Morgan is an English broadcaster
although he's well known outside of the
UK as well he's a journalist writer and
TV personality
he began his career in the UK in 1988 at
quite a young age
at the Sun the newspaper in 94 1994 at
29 he was appointed News of the World
editor by Rupert Murdoch the media mogul
he was the youngest editor of a British
national newspaper
in more than 50 years
from 95 to 2004 Pierce edited the Daily
Mirror and then served as first news
editorial director
from 2006 to 2007.
on TV from 2009 to 21 Pierce hosted the
ITV talk show life stories the CNN Chat
Show Piers Morgan Live from 2011 to
2014. the ITV breakfast program Good
Morning Britain from 2015 to 2021 and
was a judge
on both America's Got Talent from 06 to
11 and Britain's Got Talent from 07 to
2010. in 2008
he won the Celebrity Apprentice U.S
appearing with future U.S president
Donald Trump
we're going to talk today about Pierce's
career about uh being a journalist and a
celebrity as well about interacting with
celebrities but I think we're going to
start with
a brief discussion about an interview
that pierce conducted with me in the UK
a couple of weeks ago as of the taping
date of this interview and discussion um
so it seems to have attracted a fair bit
of positive attention I would say
perhaps for both of us and what what do
you make of it
well first of all it showed me what my
belief was before I interviewed you
which is that you are an internet
phenomenon uh in all guises the
attention that the interview attracted
online was uh by us our standards of our
fledgling show and network of six months
or so absolutely staggering in fact uh
right up there with my first interview
which was Donald Trump
um so I found that very interesting to
go into a world on YouTube in particular
in which you are so dominant and uh so
well known to see that an interview
could be cut up in the way that we did
it with various clips and see each of
them be watched by millions and millions
of people and I found that very
interesting uh it also played into my
sort of sense that uh the most
interesting interviews actually are with
people who have something to say you
know you and I both know that we've
interviewed lots of people over the
years uh who often don't have very much
to say for themselves and they could be
the most famous people on the planet but
be incredibly boring I would I would
rather take interesting controversial
polarizing perhaps divisive people or
certainly the way that they are
portrayed perhaps by the media and
interview those types of people because
it makes for more interesting interviews
so I found the experience of
interviewing you fascinating
um I it lived up to every expectation it
was surprisingly moving uh you got
surprisingly emotional at one stage
which I wasn't expecting
um but I think that it also I thought
showed you in an extremely good light
and I don't mean that as false flattery
I just think that you came over as to me
very sincere when you showed that
emotion and it also showed me that even
someone like you that's been criticized
a lot as well as praised that certain
things do permeate your skin and do
genuinely upset you and I was surprised
by that but I also thought that appeared
to be very genuine so I thought the
whole experience for me Jordan was
fascinating
um I think I said to my three sons who
are all in their 20s they were the most
excited I'd ever seen them about an
interview outside of Cristiano Ronaldo
our mutual friend from the world of
football
um which I found very interesting
because they're three boys in their 20s
all quite different but they all watch
YouTube avidly and they perceive you to
be the sort of king of YouTube up there
with Joe Rogan and a few others and so
they found it an utterly compelling
interview and they were able to compare
it to many that you'd done and felt that
it was right up there with one of the
best they'd seen so I was very pleased
professionally
that actually I felt I'd conducted a
good interview but I do come back to the
the basic premise I think of any
interviewer you're only really as good
as the tools that you work with and in
your case you came uh I think prepared
to be very open to be very honest to be
uh emotional and I found that actually
very moving
so so you said a couple of things there
I would say on the technological front
that I thought were very interesting so
one of the things about YouTube I would
say perhaps that distinguishes it in
some way from Legacy TV is that YouTube
really Rewards
straightforward untrammeled and
unscripted discussion and it's really
what people expect on the platform and
the fact that the discussions can go for
a long while without any of the somewhat
artificial constraints that are placed
on the broadcast media means that people
can and or are more likely to reveal
themselves in all their positive and
negative aspects and I think that's part
of the reason that Rogan has become so
popular apart from the fact that Jill
always asks questions that are actually
questions
right he's always in some sense honestly
digging for information rather than
trying to set someone up or play for a
cheap laugh or a cheap a cheap takedown
which is something that's very
characteristic of a certain type of
journalist and
you that doesn't play well at all on
YouTube interestingly enough uh it makes
people Infamous very rapidly and so it's
an interesting medium in that regard
partly because of the lack of
restriction on bandwidth and then you
also mentioned the clips issue and one
of the things that's quite remarkable
about YouTube and and makes talking
there much different than publishing a
book let's say uh well first of all the
audience is much broader on YouTube than
it is on the publishing front by an
order of magnitude likely which is a lot
but also you can't sell a book by the
sentence or the paragraph but YouTube
videos are infinitely fractionable and
you can clip one minute or three minutes
or 10 minutes or 15 minutes and there's
an independent market for every one of
those length of clips and so that's a
very interesting
new technological possibility to delve
into and you've seen Tick Tock emerge in
YouTube shorts and Instagram all these
social media platforms that have their
own culture that capitalize on that
capacity to fractionate uh to
fractionate YouTube or to fractionate
video
and so it's it's very interesting to try
to contend with all that I also thought
for what it's worth that
you uh talk to me in a very
straightforward Manner and I certainly
appreciated that uh I had many people on
my team who were concerned about the
potential
manner in which the interview might
proceed not least because we've had
plenty of fun with British journalists
before
um although that often turned out well
but but you also said during that
interview or maybe before maybe it was
before we talked that you had been
thinking about listening in a way that
was somewhat new for you or at least
knew in part I mean everybody learns as
they go along and so I was curious
afterwards about what exactly that meant
because I really felt that during the
interview you did listen to me and that
we had and vice versa hopefully and that
as a consequence we had
we genuinely communicated and I think
that that was part of the reason that
made the interview successful
yeah I mean it actually it was my middle
son who's a young actor and photographer
and listens avidly to YouTube and uh
most of your stuff he's watched in
recent years uh most of Joe Rogan's
stuff he's watched and he said Dad look
you can't do your normal Sledgehammer
act you can't just go in and start
interrupting every five seconds like you
normally do which is a it's a fault line
of mine it works well actually when
you're interviewing uh a politician
who's trying to obfuscate or answer
different questions or simply avoid the
one you're asking sometimes you do have
to be slightly bully boy in the way you
interrupt a politician to get an answer
out of them so it's a different
technique but actually the point that my
son Stanley made to me was that said Dad
if you want to get the best out of
Jordan Peterson he said trust me you
have to listen and so that was
constantly in the back of my mind he was
actually at the back of a studio as you
know with with my youngest son Bertie
and he was adamant that that was the way
I would get the best out of you and he
was completely right and it was a
learning curve for me it might sound
slightly odd that I'm getting to this
stage of my life 57 years old I've been
a journalist for you know since I was in
my early 20s to suddenly learn the art
of interview but I've been through many
guises as a journalist and interviewer
when you're a newspaper interviewer as I
was for many years or I did Big
interviews also the GQ Magazine often
the interviewer can talk a lot to get a
one-line revelation so you can keep
talking keep talking keep talking and
then and then lull your your interviewee
into saying something that maybe you
were trying to get it's a very different
discipline on television or on any form
of of on-camera interview and I was also
struck by the fact this wasn't the first
person who'd given me the advice to
listen I remember the great sir David
Frost who did with the Watergate
interviews with Richard Nixon some of
the great interviews ever seen in
political journalism and he always said
to me the most powerful tool of any
television interviewer is silent
because the the interviewee will always
fill that void
at some stage after one second two
seconds three seconds four seconds an
interviewee will fill the Gap they won't
just sit there in in silence too and
sometimes the most powerful Revelations
you can get from people come when they
have their own moment to really think
about what they're going to say and they
say it and if you're too busy as you
said earlier and I've been very guilty
of this myself
of talking too much expressing your own
opinions not really listening to what
the person is saying then you can
sometimes miss these moments of real
gold which come actually from the power
of Silence so I think that um you know I
think the experience I had with you is
really informative to me of when you're
interviewing somebody obviously very
intelligent obviously very used to doing
interviews uh perhaps coming with a
slight sense of Suspicion after what
happened with you on on channel 4 news
and I watched that interview live as I
told you and I just felt that interview
I know the interviewer Kathy Newman and
I felt that she didn't really know who
you were hadn't done quite enough
Research into what you really felt and
what you really thought and have made a
series of presumptions about you which
you were able to bat away quite quickly
and it made for very uncomfortable
viewing if you were a Channel 4 News
viewer because it was quite clear that
you were slightly on Parallel Lines so I
think that
um yeah I I found our experience really
really good actually I felt that
um had I done my political interview
technique with you I think you would
have clammed up it would have been we
wouldn't have clammed up but I think it
would have been a much more yeah
confrontational exchange which I wasn't
seeking to get because I actually agree
with a lot of what you say so it to me
it does depend who the interviewee is it
might depend too on well it might also
depend on
exactly what the purpose of the stage is
so if you're a political actor let's say
and you're acting instrumentally so you
have a purpose in the interview that's a
priori then you're you're going to be
inclined as the person being interviewed
to craft your words and to make sure you
don't step in anything toxic and to
deflect anything that might be too
penetrating and so what that seems to me
to necessitate on the part of an
investigative journalist is a much more
adversarial and antagonistic stance
because the journalist is going to be
required especially if the interviewee
is obfuscating or deceiving to have to
dig with a relatively sharp blade and so
I can really see that there's utility in
that adversarial stance when what you're
trying to uncover is a web of intrigue
and self-serving instrumentalism and
deception and this also segues quite
interestingly I think into the main one
of the main topics I want to talk to you
about today which is uh something
approximating temperament and fame and
so one of the Cardinal personality
Dimensions is agreeable illness and
agreeable people it's really a maternal
Dimension and agreeable people are
compassionate and polite they're very
interested in people and in serving
people and it's likely a dimension that
maximizes the capacity to take care of
the the weak and the infirm and infants
and The Outsiders and now the
disadvantage to being agreeable is that
you can be taken advantage of because
you can't stand up for yourself very
well partly because of your
self-sacrificing nature let's say and so
you can be a pushover and then become
resentful and angry and bitter and um
and feel that you're in an unfair World
giving all the time and never receiving
on the other side you have
the disagreeable temperament which is
more masculine and I say that because
women are reliably higher in
agreeableness and Men reliably lower and
that's true cross-culturally and it
maximizes in egalitarian countries and
so what happens in
journalism is that
journalists tend to be selected for two
personality traits perhaps more but at
least two they're extroverted because
they like to talk to people and they
like to talk and they have lots to say
and they're verbally fluid but they're
also disagreeable
and the problem with those two traits
extroversion and disagreeableness is
they tilt people towards narcissism
so and it's what was it nature I think
the German philosopher said great men
are seldom credited with their stupidity
and so
you you need you need these traits of
extroversion and being disagreeable to
put yourself in the public eye and to
enable you to be adversarial but the
there's a set of probable sins that go
along with that and those include the
sins let's say of narcissism now if
you're conscientious and you keep your
word you can ameliorate that a guy like
having disagreeable people around
because they tell you what they will
tell you what they think they don't pull
any punches and that can be harsh and
even callous at times but at least you
get the damn information whereas
agreeable people are always trying to
keep the peace at any cost including the
cost of their own well-being so you so
in your situation this is what I'm very
curious about you have to be adversarial
and you have to be antagonistic to the
degree that you're uncovering
um deception and and obfuscation those
sorts of things
to the degree that you have to counter
the tricks that people are bringing to
bear on the situation one of the things
I guess that makes YouTube different and
Rogan in particular is I don't think
Rogan
Rogan almost never talks to people who
are doing that
right he just like he I've talked to him
for example about speaking with
politicians and he tends not to speak
with them
and I think the reason for that is that
he's not interested in that adversarial
discussion and he doesn't want his
platform to be used for people who are
trying to score political points now and
fair enough and that's worked very well
for Rogan and I understand exactly why
he does that and I don't like to conduct
adversarial interviews either but it's
still the case that
there is a need for that adversarial
conduct
on the journalistic front if part of the
rule of Journalism is to keep dishonest
narcissists as as honest as possible and
so obviously one of the things that
you're
attempting to calibrate properly I
presume is
well how much you listen and allow the
conversation to unfold and how much you
dig without digging too much and without
being an utter prick about it right
because obviously it's possible to go
too far on that front and so and my
suspicions are that you also have the
temperament to be able to engage in a
fight
and without that you can't be
adversarial so how you said you're still
learning to do that the silence issue is
interesting too because I think that's
particularly tough on broadcast TV
because you're called upon in some sense
to fill every valuable second
and then to let a pause occur
you have to be willing to risk the
potential price of dead space and that's
quite
in intimidating if you're
while using up valuable broadcast space
which isn't such an issue on YouTube
let's say but there's very weird
constraints in broadcast TV that people
aren't aware of when they're just
watching it so
so tell me about the adversarial
relationship and and how you think
you've managed that part positively and
also negatively
yeah I'm gonna give you two great
examples I think where I got it right
and then got it wrong uh one was when I
was at CNN and Sandy Hook happened the
the mass shooting at the school and I'd
been editor of the Daily Mirror back in
the UK in 1996 when the dunblane school
massacre happened in Scotland where 16
young children were killed by a lone
gunman and so I at the time campaigned
in the UK for much tougher gun control
measures which all were passed by a
combination of left and right-wing
governments John majors and then Tony
Blairs so it was much easier here to
affect change because very few people
actually had guns so I was under no
delusion that America is a very
different culture to be waging a similar
campaign but what it brought back to me
when Sandy Hook happened were the
emotions I had when dunblane had
occurred and how horrific it was and how
just this idea of of 16 in dunblane and
20 children in Sandy Hook having their
lives snuffed away by some Maniac with a
gun that it seemed to me unconscionable
that any society could not want to
affect some change to stop it happening
again and yet recently in America we had
another mass shooting in a school it
almost identical in the word it was
carried out and nothing had been done
since Sandy Hook so if you take the
apocryphal I think it was Einstein quote
of definition of insanity of doing the
same thing over and over again expecting
a different result well also I would say
the definition of insanity is doing
nothing again and again and expecting
same thing not to happen so when I blew
up at CNN at the time
against the NRA for example it came from
a position of real raw emotion I'd I'd I
could think of only a handful of times
in my career when I've been rendered to
Tears by a news story dunblame was one
of them and Sandy Hook was another so I
was being driven by genuine raw emotion
no question and I think in the early
stages of my coverage of that story on
on CNN
it really resonated with people people
thought it was very powerful it was
compelling uh and I was I was broadly
right that something had to be done but
I would say I slightly over egged the uh
the the emotional souffle and I think it
began to have the opposite effect to
what I hoped so I hope to genuinely
affect change but I couldn't stop being
over emotional in the interviews I did
with some of these uh probe NRA pro-gun
people that were coming on the show and
ended up shouting at them losing my
temper with them slightly straying into
performative art perhaps even straying
into a dash of narcissism myself where
you start to believe your own hype you
start to read the media saluting what
you're doing I was getting emails from
Barbra Streisand congratulating me and
so on it's all very intoxicating but of
course it can if you're a if you're not
careful and I think it happened to me
there it can lead to you actually
achieving the complete opposite to what
you hope and in the end I think all I'm
managed to do with my over-emotional
response over time was probably sell
more guns in America which was a great
opposite effect right to what I wanted
because people thought this guy is the
new George III uh he seems to have
forgotten we got rid of the Brits with
guns we don't want a guy with this
accent telling us how to lead Our Lives
Etc uh and I would say similarly in the
UK in the pandemic in the first wave in
early 2020
I built up a reputation pretty quickly
for skewering British politicians on air
in a very very aggressive and volatile
manner in which I felt they were
completely dropping the ball
collectively as a government making a
series of catastrophic and deadly
mistakes and I saw it incumbent on me to
try and almost Hammer them into making
better decisions and for a long time I
think I would say that I did a very good
job of that but again I think towards
the end I overdid things a little bit
and when I look back at some of the
later interviews I was perhaps trying to
recreate the theater of whatever before
which was very organic and real and when
you start to recreate something that's
organic it ceases to be organic and so I
think those were two those were two good
examples where a lot of people would
have been cheering me on uh but also in
both cases what happened there in the UK
was the government actually pulled all
their ministers from any interviews with
me for eight months they just did a
complete blanket ban
um and I and that doesn't help anybody
because then my viewers don't get served
by anything they have no ability to hear
from people in government about what's
going to be happening so I felt in both
cases that I let myself down in the end
albeit with the right intentions and the
danger line for anyone that does that
kind of interviewing
is where it Strays into performative art
rather than organic anger and emotion so
I don't regret the early emotion and
anger but I do regret the way it strayed
into something a little different and I
think that's a really interesting lesson
for people if you're going to do those
kind of slightly more volatile
interviews and I do think sometimes you
have to as a journalist I like passion
in journalists I like emotion but never
lose track of actually what you're doing
and how you're feeling and never never
try and replicate something that you've
done before because it will always come
across as slightly fake okay so so let's
take that apart a little bit so the
first thing is that the first thing you
said there was that
when you're being lauded by a lot of
people for your actions
first of all we might point out that
it's useful to take that seriously right
because one of the things you want to
see in someone is that they are
responsive to social response
the person who's not social responsive
to social response is either completely
unskilled or Psychopathic or or maybe is
in a different category altogether where
they can handle public response
appropriately which is very very
difficult so you had every reason if
people were responding positively to you
to assume that what you're doing was
broadly regarded as positive and
therefore might even be positive but
then you said
it it it enticed you in an egotistical
direction to some degree so one of the I
spent a lot of time
trying to understand Adolf Hitler
psychologically
and and in some sense I would say trying
to develop some sympathy for him insofar
as that was possible and I think you
developed Sympathy For People by putting
yourself in their position
and that's very difficult to do with
someone like Adolf Hitler first of all
it's very unpleasant to do that but it's
also very challenging because at minimum
he had a very complex life but you
imagine
here's a statement you can tell me what
you think of this if if 20 million of
your countrymen are telling you that
you're the savior of their country who
are you to disagree
and so and so you you wonder why someone
like Hitler could have his ego blown up
to the proportions that it became blown
up to and the answer is well
do you really think that you'd be able
to resist the positive blandishments of
so many people because that in itself
could easily be a form of egotism right
I don't care what people think it's like
well yeah you probably do and you
probably should and and then the
question is well how do you keep
yourself straight when you are the
target of positive adulation and so one
of it you said you should know what
you're doing so one possibility is and I
think I learned this mostly from Carl
Jung is that you need to distinguish
yourself
from the principles for which you stand
right because so one of the things that
happens to me quite often is that people
tell me how helpful my work has been
and I think to the degree that I can
think this I think well it's not
surprising that it's been helpful in
large part because it's not exactly my
work
a lot of the things I've learned and
perhaps the vast majority no doubt the
vast majority of the things that I've
learned I've learned because I've
studied great thinkers who in turn have
studied great thinkers and so I've been
able to derive a certain amount of
wisdom and I'm able to communicate that
but I'm
doing my best to ensure that I separate
myself from that wisdom and that's a
hard thing to do because of course here
I am as a person as well
and the ideas that are being transmitted
through me are focused on me at that
moment for that reason but it's very
difficult that's the idea of rendering
unto God what's God's and unto Caesar
what's Caesars in some sense right is
that you have to so you remember
it's okay to attract the positive
attention because it reflects well on
the principles that you're trying to
espouse but as soon as this becomes
about your status
and your specific success and your
instrumental maneuvering in the world
then you replace what is being praised
with yourself and that's a sin of Pride
and the consequences of that will is
that you'll definitely fall into a pit
and on that point is interesting you've
made me think of something very specific
which I think is a good example
Tony Blair was a very successful British
prime minister for many years he was
elected for three terms
but I remember after 9 11 he flew to the
United States and he spoke to Congress
and said he we would stand shoulder to
shoulder with the American people and
Congress gave him a lengthy Standing
Ovation and it was an image that went
round the world and I could almost see
Blair in Congress standing there taking
this extraordinary adulation from the
most powerful room in the world
and then basking in the glory of of his
position here is the great supporter and
defender of the United States at the
most difficult hour and it was almost
like he puffed up visit me in front of
us like a peacock you know he was loving
me right he was loving this attention
albeit in a very serious time and then
you cut forward to the Iraq War
uh within two years and I am absolutely
convinced that Tony Blair's ego drove
him to wage that war to go along with
the Iraq War when every part of his
legal brain he was a lawyer uh and his
slightly you know left to Center
political brain would have told him this
was Insanity that actually to go it
alone without a United Nations second
resolution which would be endorsing uh
military conflict
that without that this was mad and I had
many conversations with him at number 10
Downing Street in his flat but we
literally would share a beer and have a
chatter battle with and I could see that
it was the the problem he'd dug himself
was that he from that moment he became
the peacock opening his his wings
proudly to soak in the adulation of the
United States
um that he then felt almost a duty to go
along with whatever action the United
States government took even if it was
against the British national interest
and even as it turned out if it turned
out to be a pretty much a disaster the
Iraq War and I I genuinely think it was
the process you've just described where
the initial Instinct of going to
Washington
standing shoulder to shoulder with
America was absolutely correct so the
praise that he was getting was
completely Justified but it then turned
him into something which I think looking
back he must surely regret he probably
would never admit that but I I saw it
happen to him where the the ego needed
to continue to be praised by America and
he had to make a calculation do I go
with the Americans on this Iraq war
Journey or do I do what the British
people want me to do which is to not go
on that wall 1.7 million people marched
through London many of them carrying
placards which I had produced as editor
of the Daily Mirror which was the labor
supporting newspaper and he was a labor
prime minister and these prakyards said
no war and you'll see if you go back and
look at the footage you'll see thousands
of people clutching Daily Mirror placa
so he and I had a real split over this
and when I when I looked back it was it
was exactly the way that you just
described that process right right
initially correct and then sucked in
through ego and perhaps a bit of
narcissism into a place he he would
never have instinctively wanted to be
right well okay so let's talk about this
politically and theologically for a
minute so I was in the UK in London when
Queen Elizabeth passed away and and it
was quite remarkable to see
the response it was quite something to
see the Brits put on this amazing show
which happened very rapidly which is
extremely well organized and very very
very well done very beautiful and which
I believe attracted more viewers on TV
than any event human history which is
really saying something and
I really like the monarchical system
because
I think the queen serves a confessional
role for politicians
she'd reigned over 13 different Prime
Ministers and you can imagine that it
would be very useful for someone who's
in a position like Tony Blair or any
other prime minister to have to go face
this woman who's seen everyone from from
Churchill to to the president or to the
to the president present prime minister
uh lizas and to feel themselves in some
sense less dominant and less powerfully
positioned than at least someone in the
room and to have to do that on a regular
basis and that strikes me as a
replication in the secular realm of what
confession and the search for Redemption
and atonement was when it was practiced
religiously let me tell you a story so
back in ancient Mesopotamia
the Mesopotamian Emperor uh was required
to undertake a ritual at New Year's
and I believe that a fair bit of our New
Year's ritual mythology you know the the
death of the old year The Old Man and
the rebirth of the baby their Echoes of
this Mesopotamian structure the idea
that the old year is coming to an end in
the new year is going to be rekindled
with all the possibilities that go along
with it and the fact that people make
resolutions which are some sense
confessional I did these things wrong
and here's how I could improve in the
future when there's a new year the
Mesopotamian Emperor would be taken
outside the walls of of of the central
Mesopotamian City so out into No Man's
Land right outside the safety of the
community and then he would be required
to strip himself of all his tingly Garb
and kneel and then a priest would slap
him and then he would be reforced to
recount all the ways that year he wasn't
a good Marduk Marduk was the
monotheistic deity of the Mesopotamians
and he had eyes all the way around his
head and he spoke magic words and so
mardic was a god of careful attention
and proper speech and so the
Mesopotamian Emperor had to
reflect on how he hadn't upheld the
proper principles of sovereignty
as a consequence of being humiliated
before before uh what would you say a
Transcendent power that was greater than
his and when I said earlier that you
have to remember that it's not you but
the principles for which you stand that
is something like the proper ordering
and so it would have been reasonable for
for prime minister Blair to be very
pleased with the fact that the UK was
standing in solidarity with the United
States but not pleased not appropriate
for him to be pleased that Tony Blair
was on the side of the Americans
because it's actually not about Tony
Blair
and so and getting that confused and and
then you've got to have sympathy for
people too because it's not surprising
that people would get that confused I
mean one of the things I've noticed
about celebrities it's a big danger
imagine
you become famous and as a consequence
of that now you have a Persona and
that's
you defined by the social
crowd and there's a certain brand
significance that goes along without us
reputational significance and a value
even an economic value but the problem
is is it can become a trap
because if you can only be what you've
already been then you can't be anything
new and that's where people fall into
this trap that you described of
something like self-mimicry right this
worked for me before look at the effect
It produced I just will do that again
but then you're instantly false eh
you're instantly false when you do that
it's like you're sacrificing your future
self for whatever your past self once
attained and then then you lose that
spark that actually is likely the
driving force of whatever made you
attractive to begin with yeah I
completely agree and I I you know I
always say to my sons really my basic
rule of life is is try never to go back
full stop with anything it's never the
same there's always a reason that you've
moved on from whatever it is and to try
and replicate previous behaviors to try
and replicate previous relationships to
try and replicate perhaps a job that you
once loved and lost to try and go back I
think you often forget why you left in
the first place or why things didn't
work out you know you read it and see it
all the time
um you tend to you know memory tends to
sugarcoat things right it's only when
you actually if you do allow yourself to
fall back into these previous habits or
behaviors or whatever it may be that you
then realize it wasn't what you thought
now the mind I think plays tricks with
you a little bit so I think that I do
think particularly with politicians
particularly with uh Sportsmen
entertainers you're right about the
brand thing is they can very quickly get
pigeonholed as to this or that or this
and then they start to play up to the
thing which they were originally
identified as being and maybe it was
what they're actually like or maybe it
wasn't but either way it becomes a very
difficult thing to then escape from you
become tagged with that you know I know
pop stars who are still seen as the
nicest people in Showbiz I know them to
be utterly horrific conversely I know
you know people I've met in business or
politics who have terrible reputations
but actually are very nice people so
it's an interesting thing that that
public branding of people can be
instantaneous and very long lasting and
often completely wrong but the danger
for any public figure is to try and play
up to your caricature now I think the
the one the one Saving Grace you can
have is self-awareness
to me there are two types of public
figures those who've got self-awareness
and those who don't I think that I have
a big Persona a big perhaps slightly
caricature Persona sometimes
um I'd like to I'd like to deliberately
antagonize a great debate and so on uh
but I always do it with a a sense of
self-awareness and the times I described
to you earlier where I've slightly lost
the plot and become a performative
theatrical artist if you like rather
than a proper journalist of when I've
forgotten the self-awareness streak when
I've been driven by adulation and praise
usually into thinking that somehow right
this is the new me and this is great and
I'm going to be this person rather than
just being honest with yourself about
who you are you know I think I'm pretty
aware of who I am warts and all and some
of the traits which other people see as
being a me disagreeable I'm very relaxed
about uh I felt I'm less relaxed about
some of the more positive traits you
know when people say oh you're such a
nice person but it sounds almost brand
damaging to me me I don't want to be
just nice I can't think of anything
worse than being nice I'd rather be
challenging I'd rather be right right
it's a shallow version yeah why would
you aspire to just be nice it seems it
seems to me that people who are
inherently known as nice people a they
rarely live up to that brand in my
experience uh in in terms of high
profile people I know
um and it must be an unbearable pressure
to constantly wake up every day and
think I have to be nice all day when in
fact your your natural and more honest
Instinct may be to be disagreeable from
time to time because that's what you're
actually feeling and often you'd be
right by the way to be feeling
disagreeable about something so I do
think that I mean I I think I just
struck by something you told me when we
I interviewed you that you felt as
you've got older uh you've evolved and
you've learned things about yourself and
I feel exactly the same way I'm not the
same person I was I think I still have
the same
sense of uh of Virtues which perhaps
were instilled in me when I was a child
by my family had a very strong family a
very strong upbringing but I do think
I've evolved as a person and I do think
if you don't evolve as a person I'm not
sure what you're doing here it's you
know the the world's a tough difficult
complex place and you should evolve
emotionally as you get older and
hopefully in the right direction I think
you turned into an actor so I spent a
lot of time I've spent a lot of time
analyzing pop culture and I focused a
lot as many of the people who are
watching and listening to this will know
on analyzing uh the great Disney
animated Classics which were
extraordinarily influential popular
Productions and one of the movies that
has struck me most particularly although
I don't think it's the greatest of the
Disney movies is Pinocchio and there are
a number of so Pinocchio is a puppet so
someone is pulling this his strings
right there's forces behind the scenes
that are making him who he is and he's
unconscious he doesn't know it but he's
he has a good father who is a very
positive figure who sends them out in
the world to free himself of the behind
the strings
marionette players
and he faces a number of Temptations and
there's four cardinal Temptations which
I think are extremely well laid out one
is Hedonism narrow and shallow Hedonism
and that's played out in the scenes of
Pleasure Island and the consequences of
becoming a narrow hedonist is that you
end up as a voiceless slave that's how
that
you end up uh turned into a donkey that
can do nothing Bray sold as slaves to
work in the salt mine so that's the
fruits of hedonism
another scene that perplexed me for a
long time was that Pinocchio is enticed
into being an actor
and I thought what in the world does
that mean because the people who made
this movie were obviously Hollywood
types and what's so wrong with being an
actor but the answer is to be found in
the discussion that we were just having
if you're playing a role and you're
doing it as a fictional character and
you're playing a role in a movie let's
say and everyone knows that what you're
doing is fictional that's one thing but
if you're an actor who's attempting to
play a role for your own egotistical
gratification then that's a catastrophe
and what happens in the Pinocchio movie
is that he is enticed into going on
stage as a puppet and he does a wild
dance and Tangles himself up in his own
strings and ends up face down in front
of the crowd and then also enslaved oh
the one of the other Temptations Just
interestingly enough because it's
germane to our current culture is that
the fox and the cat who are agents of
Mephistopheles essentially also entice
Pinocchio into
playing the playing the sick victim
and so that's actually how the entice
them originally to go to Pleasure Island
to become hedonistic they tell him that
he's sick and unable and has been
victimized and needs a break and as a
consequence of his poor victimized
position it's perfectly okay for him to
be narrowly and self-servingly
hedonistic and so it's a lovely
narrative layout of the sort of plethora
of moral problems that beset people as
they try to transform themselves let's
say into real boys because of course
that's what the movie's about and it's
very interesting to sketch out the
nature of those Temptations this this
acting Temptation you see celebrities
become their own mimics they be like
Elvis in some sense became an Elvis IM
imitator by the time that he ended you
know he came to the to the near the end
of his life I mean he could still put on
a wicked performance but you could see
that immense pressure
the category pressure building around
them and you can imagine how intense
that is especially perhaps at the time
he lived because he was a singular
celebrity there's lots of celebrities
now but there were very there were much
fewer back then
and the pressure to
to abide by the way you've been defined
must be almost overwhelming and it isn't
obvious that we really know how to
rectify that I think the the confession
ID is a good one is that you need to
keep your inadequacies foremost in your
mind and you need to serve some
principles that are higher than yourself
but that's easy to say in the abstract
it's not so easy to actually do it when
you're the one being tempted yeah I
think you you also rightly said you have
to have people around you who perhaps
are disagreeable enough to be completely
bluntly honest honest with you you know
I whether it's my mother or one of my
brothers or my sister or my sons in
particular encouraged them to be very
independent-minded and to let me know if
they see or hear something I do which
they think is wrong and explain why and
they do that regularly and I find that
litmus test from people who really know
you better than anybody else so they
really understand when you're making a
fool of yourself or just behaving like a
bit of a bit of a dick right you just
see someone is going to tell you and one
of the big problems with modern
celebrity is because I've interviewed a
lot of very famous people
is that they often surround themselves
with pure sycophancy and they don't
tolerate anyone drifting outside in sick
of fancy all the teams around them are
so fearful of losing their very cushy
jobs that they render themselves as
useless permanently to avoid upsetting
so they may almost be almost wrongly
second-guessing the people they work for
who might be perfectly okay people
because they think if they're not
sycophantic they're going to lose their
job so there's constant kind of pressure
to blow smoke up the derriers of these
people which doesn't help the Stars
themselves it certainly doesn't help the
people who work for them who are
behaving in such a ridiculous Manner and
the celebrities I know who I think
really Thrive over a long period of time
they always tend to have people in their
Entourage who are straight talkers who
literally will save them in front of
people stop behaving like a dick
literally and you need those people
because if you don't have those people
in your entourage or whoever it may be
manager and agent I had a fantastic
manager
who sadly died of pancreatitis three
years ago and he's one of my closest
friends and he transformed my career he
was the one that put me on Celebrity
Apprentice which I won and that led to
joining CNN and replacing Larry King and
then the morning show he did all these
things for me and we were very very
close and he died literally four days
after getting ill with pancreas it was
horrific but he was the one really who
would call me sometimes
having watched maybe on the morning show
watch me in La at 11 at night and he'd
see or hear me do something which he
felt he had to say something about it
and he called me and say you shouldn't
have said that that you that's not you
that's not what you believe I know it
isn't and the way you phrase that the
way you went after someone he hated if
it ever felt like I was punching down
not up yeah right he thought I was at my
best when I he thought I was at my best
when I was basically producing Robin
Hood TV where I would be the Robin Hood
figure looking after the downtrodden
against the sheriffs of Nottingham be
they from energy companies or political
parties or you know corrupt tycoons
whatever it may be he said you're at
your absolute best when you're Robin
Hood right when you start to behave like
the Sheriff of Nottingham you're a it's
not you it's not what's in your heart I
know you and B is performative [ __ ]
which you shouldn't be drifting into and
it doesn't work on any level now I
really miss that in my life that guy
having those kind of conversations
because you you know a I have to respect
the person to want to listen to it so
when you lose someone like that in your
life it's really difficult because I had
such huge personal respect for him and I
knew we've been through an awful lot
together he nearly died 10 years before
he'd been in Cedar Sinai hospital for
three months uh with a staff infection
he'd be in a coma he wasn't expected to
survive he'd have the last rights and so
on and when he came out he got fired
when his company merged and I was the
only one of 50 clients who went with him
so he went from being one of the biggest
power agents in Hollywood to one client
me and then we rebuilt things very
successfully so we had a real Bond
professionally and personally but I
think everybody needs someone like that
who is who knows you who knows you and
knows what knows when you're not being
yourself well that's a beneficial
adversary that's the uh translation by
the way for the word that God uses to
describe Eve in the Garden of Eden help
me means in the original Hebrew it means
beneficial adversary and it's someone to
have around this is what a marriage can
do for you too if you're fortunate
because you have someone there who can
help you calibrate your your aim as a
consequence of continued disagreement in
some real sense because there isn't much
difference between disagreement thinking
this brings us to two things I would say
so there's an immense
push in our society right now to insist
that identity be entirely subjectively
defined right which means that as God
said to Moses I am that I am
and that's a very difficult that's a
very dangerous thing for people to take
upon themselves to say I am to be
treated only the way that I Define and
we just spent a fair bit of time
outlining why that's so wrong
because
you're what keeps you sane this friend
of yours this agent you had he was part
of what kept you sane so you're moving
up the status hierarchy and it might not
even be obvious to you while you're
moving up when you're punching up and
when you're punching down because your
relative position is actually changing
so I've run into this problem I
criticized a swimsuit model on the cover
of Sports Illustrated and an actress
actor who had undergone a sex change
publicly on Twitter and I got kicked off
of Twitter for the latter criticism and
one of the criticisms I faced was that I
was punching down and it didn't really
occur to me when I was making those
comments that I was punching down
because the actor or actress that I
criticized was quite famous in now I'm
having pronoun trouble in his her own
right and I was also irritated that
these fashion spread that was conducted
after the sex change operation got 1.5
million Instagram likes which didn't
strike me as all that socially useful
but it's not easy to figure out when
your own position is shifting
when you're going after someone let's
say at your level of influence or higher
and when you've even accidentally
entered into The Fray that you shouldn't
be entering into and brought too much
force to bear on the person but also
what would you say undermine your own
authority by doing so and so having
these disagreeable people around who say
you know you're not being who you are
and you're not who you think you are and
you're not aiming properly that's
actually how you stabilize your identity
and so identity is actually socially
negotiated if you're healthy identity is
socially negotiated all the time and in
that has to be a fair good leave-in of
criticism because it stops you from
getting above yourself if you're
fortunate and so you have to listen to
how other people Define you but then we
you run into the adulation problem
perhaps and then if you listen too much
to how other people Define you well
that's its own egotistical trap so but
having people around I'm fortunate
because my wife is very sensible and
she's an astute beneficial adversary and
my kids are like that too and I have a
lot of very good friends who are
what would you say their forces in their
own right
and they're perfectly willing to tell me
when they think that I haven't conducted
myself
according to the standards that I would
like to abide by and it's unbelievably
useful while navigating a complicated
situation and it is in some sense the
definition of Sanity right is to have
enough feedback around you that's
balanced so that you move forward on the
right path that is not subjectively
defined identity that's one of the
things that's so pathological about that
insistence because that just that just
swallows you up in a the ultimate
egotistical solipsism if you can be
whatever you say you are from moment to
moment and no one has any right to
object
how do you think you're going to turn
out you're going to inflate like mad
until you burst that's definitely the
case speaking of disagreeable people you
worked on
America's Got Talent with Simon Cowell
and I really like Simon Cowell for for
what it's worth I mean he's he's got
this tremendous capacity to give credit
where credit is due
which he does very well and as far as I
can tell 100 genuinely I think and I'd
sure like your comments on this that the
America has Got Talent the god Talent
platforms have brought a tremendous
amount of ability to light and it's
really quite remarkable to see him flip
from this disagreeable critic who puts
up with pretty much zero nonsense to
someone who's completely floored when
someone comes out and is genuine and
truly talented I really like the shows
that the got talent shows I watch them
quite a lot huh they often bring me to
tears which turns out not to be such a
difficult thing but it's quite something
to see people suddenly reveal something
about themselves that's so utterly
stellar and I really like watching Simon
impose his discriminating judgment
especially in a world that thinks that
all discrimination and judgment is
pathological and one of the consequences
of that is that he can bring all this
talent to light this true Talent what
did you enjoy working with with it got
talent shows and why did you do that and
and
tell me about the judge process I'd like
to know more about the whole background
Enterprise yeah so I I'd known Simon a
long time from when I was the show
business editor of the Sun newspaper
doing all the pop pop culture stuff and
Simon was trying to basically be a
record company anr man flogging you know
records and trying to get a paper to
write about him so I I got to know him
liked him very much he was a great force
of Personality he wasn't on television
then no one knew who he was outside the
music business then he becomes the
biggest TV star on the planet with
American Idol I mean like stratospheric
Fame which happened interestingly not in
the first series or season but the
second season it suddenly exploded
and so when he he took me out for lunch
after I lost my job editing the Daily
Mirror
and a little bit of big controversy here
we'd published some photographs of
British troops purportedly abusing Iraqi
uh civilians uh illegally which had just
followed the Abu ghraib scandal in
America where their troops had been
doing the same thing the government and
the regiment said these were fake
photographs I was fired I'm still not
sure exactly what those photographs were
but that was the end of my career as a
newspaper editor after 10 years and
Simon took me for lunch uh very near
where I'm talking to you actually in
Kensington and West London went for a
nice meal and he pulled out a napkin and
put it on the table
and he said you know what's really
missing on in World television he said
um the old Gong Show in America and
opportunity no and a show very similar
show in the UK called opportunity knocks
and and then new faces and they were
basically he said any Talent not just
singers but any Talent
and he said my idea is we'd have three
judges you'd have a a tough meanie who
keeps everything you know honest you'd
have a slightly crazy person uh he said
like Paula Abdul was an idol with a big
heart but slightly crazy and you'd have
someone
probably a comedian who would make
people laugh and you'd have the perfect
judging panel so then he he we did a we
did a pilot for this show it's quite
interesting Genesis of the story for
Britain's Got Talent was originally
going to be called Paul O'Grady's Got
Talent who's a British Entertainer uh
but he had a huge uh falling out with
the network and left and then Simon said
well that unfortunately we're not going
to do it so it was all shelved in the UK
where he was intending to launch it six
weeks later I'm thinking my brand new
prime time TV career is is over before
it even started and I get a text from
Simon saying because I've just sold the
rights to Got Talent to NBC in America
they want to repackage it as America's
Got Talent which I immediately thought
was a brilliant idea to sort of wrap the
flag and the country and patriotism
around this this show
and he said I I can't be on it as a
judge because I'm on American Idol so I
need to find somebody as arrogant and as
obnoxious as me and judgmental and your
name is immediately sprung to mind so uh
long story short he flew me straight out
to Los Angeles I met with some NBC
Executives uh managed to [ __ ] my way
through quite a long meeting with them
and three weeks later I'm on the
Paramount movie lot in Hollywood I've
got my own trailer next to David
Hasselhoff and Regis Philbin and I'm the
judge of America's Got Talent and I'm
the new Simon Cowell which was not a
place I ever thought I'd find myself but
um it was really interesting and
assignment came to I remember never
forgot this on day one he pulled up in
his brand new Ferrari outside my trailer
and he came in and said right and I was
like this is fantastic son I can't
believe this I'm living the dream and he
said look here's the deal with our kind
of stick
you have to be right 80 of the time and
if you are and the viewers agree with
you eighty percent of the time you can
be as mean as you like right you said
you can be a straight blunt honest meme
whatever you want to call it you can be
whatever you want to be you just have to
be right 80 of the time because if
you're mean or tough or ruthless and
you're wrong a lot of the time the ACT
doesn't work right and it wasn't acting
away in a way talent shows are theater
obviously you've got people performing
on stage and whatever but I always tried
to be I think this is a key thing I
think about public life generally
I always tried to be authentic and I
think Simon's always authentic you know
he might be guided by a producer hey
this is a really good act but he doesn't
feel it and he'll say I don't like it so
he was always authentic and I picked
that up and I always tried to be very
authentic whilst being pretty blunt
pretty British pretty you know full-on
but I was always mindful of just call it
exactly as you're actually feeling it
really just be honest with yourself
never mind the audience and if you are
normally you're going to be right
because it's what they're all feeling at
home then you have to have that ability
to gauge what an audience might be
thinking but ultimately be authentic and
if you ask me what is the number one
tool of really successful people it's
authenticity they are true to themselves
the most successful people I've
encountered ultimately are authentic
they don't get drifted or pulled into
places where it's not them where they're
playing an act you do get some that come
through who I think are completely fake
and wing it and get away with it but
broadly speaking and the same applied
with the talent shows
so you could have all these acts
um and a lot of them were faking it a
lot of them were trying to be somebody
they were trying to they were trying to
be Beyonce they were trying to be
Madonna they were trying to be a dance
street with whatever it may be they were
trying to be somebody else the most
successful acts that I ever saw on the
British show and the and the American
one were the ones which were truly
authentic and I'll give an example a guy
on the second season of America's Got
Talent it's actually quite a funny story
behind this because
Simon Cowell owned the rights to the
show and he had the rights automatically
to manage any of the winners of the show
and I think even the top 10 finalists
that was built into his contract so the
second season
first season number one summer show in
America so my life has changed
dramatically second season there are two
standout early candidates for potential
winners one is a white reggae star who
was fantastic and a beautiful singing
voice and Simon literally was radiating
the word kaching every time he heard him
before because he thought this guy is a
money-making machine right in front of
me he looks the part he sounds apart
amazing singer carries himself great but
I was more drawn to the complete
opposite which was a guy called Terry
Fator and Terry Fator
was a slightly overweight uh permanently
sweating ill-fitting suited guy who had
gone up and down America for 20 years in
his van earning 500 bucks a week at most
doing a ventriloquist Act
and he'd had an extraordinary turn of
Fortune shortly before he applied to be
on America's Got Talent where his act
used to be that he would sing
Impressions himself so he would sing Roy
Orbison Crying for example and then he
would talk through puppets a turtle uh
you know and so on
and he went to do one gig and two people
turned up there's a real lesson here for
everyone two people turned up but he
still gave them the best act he could
and one of them turned out to be a
talent talent agent he said to him have
you ever tried doing the singing
Impressions through the puppets
simple thing they've changed this guy's
life so Terry fader went away and found
he could actually throw his voice
through the puppets as a singer better
than he could do it from his own mouth
and at that point his whole act changed
so he then applies to America's Got
Talent comes on stage and I immediately
find him very endearing as a personality
and I love his backstory he's the
ultimate kind of this guy's been going
20 years wanting the break this is the
moment maybe
and
as he progresses through the the
competition I keep supporting him
Simon's on my case stop being so
supportive he's going to win and I can't
make any money out of a ventriloquist go
with the other guy
go with the reggae singer I was like
Simon this guy's what this show's about
this this
ventriloquist anyway he ends up winning
mainly because I'm so effusive of my
support and by then the American viewing
public had viewed my opinion rather like
the calm on American Idol is the one
that was most significant as far as ever
concerned so he wins and Simon and a fit
of peak says I can't make any money out
of him uh so I'm not going to manage it
so the guy is left without a management
so he disappears and a guy who used to
work on the Rolling Stones management
team and was now working on his own
heard about this guy had a chat with him
and took him on decided to manage him
and just try his luck and a few months
later literally three months later Danny
Gantz all around family Entertainer in
Las Vegas one of the biggest stars on
the Strip drops dead
that's it and the casino where he
operated had to fill a massive Gap in
their schedule they didn't have an
all-around family Entertainer the
Rolling Stones management guy who'd
picked up Terry Fator recommends Terry
Fator Terry Fator does a three-month
trial he sells out every show because
grandmothers love him mothers love him
kids love him dads love him everyone
loves Terry fader he's now got 50
puppets he's singing all these amazing
songs through these crazy puppets
and on the back of the three-month trial
he signs a five-year 100 million dollar
contract to be the biggest star on the
Las Vegas Strip which if Simon Cowell
had kept the management rights would
have earned him 20 million dollars so if
you want to really piss off Simon Cowell
just say hey Simon how much money did
you make out of that ventriloquist uh um
so it's in that story in many ways it
has a lot of useful things to go with us
yeah yeah one is they'll don't judge a
book by its cover you know if you took
them purely on Aesthetics you go with
the white reggae star every day but
there was something about this guy's
personality and the uniqueness of his
act and the fact that he taken advice
from someone who was one of only two
people in an audience so never give up
always give every always give everything
everything because you never know who's
watching I say this to my actor son if
there's not a big audience in one night
you don't know if in those 20 people
there's a guy that's going to change
your life absolutely so I think you know
all these lessons from the Terry later
story he's still on the Vegas Strip now
you go to I think it's the Mirage or
whatever he is he has his own theater
named after him he signed another 100
million dollar contract he's the most
successful breakout star in the history
of any talent show ever uh and that's
his backstory and it was to me it was a
that was what the show was all about
rather like Susan Boyle yeah we remember
Susan you bet that was amazing never
never well she never sang outside of her
Village yeah and was 47 year old
spinster yeah you know who'd been
starved of oxygen at Birth and had
slight issues because of that and yet
she came on stage I'll never forget this
again never judge books by their covers
she came on stage in Glasgow I can
remember it like it was yesterday and
I'm with Simon on the British so we're
both judges on the British show with
another judge and Susan Boyle comes out
and we're talking to what are you gonna
do I'm gonna sing uh from Les Miserables
I dream a dream and we all start rolling
our eyes yeah yeah more like Mike my God
you've got to be kidding he's been a
long long day we'd seen some terrible
Talent yeah yeah and she began she began
to sing and in that moment the magic
happened it turned out she was an
unbelievably good singer she went on to
sell 30 million albums I interviewed
George Clooney yeah I interviewed George
Clooney for CNN and halfway through he
says by the way how's Susan which I have
to say she was very chuffed about yeah
yeah Robin Robin Williams I did The
Tonight Show with Robin Williams and my
manager my late great manager and Robin
Williams bangs on the door he's the
other guest and he comes into our
dressing room and does a 15-minute act
which was basically half Mrs Doubtfire
half Susan Boyle oh cool so he was Susan
Boyle but as Mrs Doubtfire just for the
two of us in our dressing room oh so so
so these two stories to me Susan in the
UK one and Terry Fator on the American
one they personified actually what the
shows should be about what the American
dream and the British dream are really
about about chasing a dream and never
giving up about having a talent and
making it work all these life lessons
really were encompassed in these two
stories uh and they could have been
ignored they may not have entered and
their lives would have you know been
what they were Terry fade has made I
don't know 300 million dollars and
everyone else's life would have been
lesser well Simon and the other judges
and the show are very good at separating
the wheat from the chaff and one of the
things I think that makes Simon so
attractive especially in our culture is
that his fundamental virtue isn't being
nice
now he's one of the things that makes
him
heartwarming weirdly enough for such a
rough character is that when someone
does well he's he's floored by it and
you can see that constantly and it's one
of the lovely things about watching the
judges period I mean the judges have
their personality pack of deals and the
fact that you have assembled the judge
panel to reflect a variety of different
personality types is very interesting
and you can see that the judges have had
long days and that sometimes they're a
bit more uh initially critical and
suspicious than they might be but that
makes it human but to see everyone on
the panel truly light up
When someone knocks it out of the park
that's so cool and it's so I think it's
such a service to people not only the
people who whose Talent is being
revealed but to everyone that's watching
it's not surprising to me that the show
has become so popular it's
extraordinarily well done and I think
Simon his ability to like or love Talent
so much that he's willing to State
forthrightly when it's not there which
was also the role that you were playing
that's uh that's truly something to be
commended I also think that
part of the reason that this show is so
popular is because that ethos of
extraordinarily penetrating criticism
and separating Excellence from falsehood
or sheer lack of talent that's very
disagreeable
because these people come to the show
and they're hoping sometimes genuinely
and sometimes narcissistically that
they're going to have their dreams
validated but if they're talentless and
narcissistic they're going to hit a
brick wall very hard and it's not that
easy to be that brick wall
no now I knew if I had a friend who
taught me something he's a very
disagreeable person he took my
personality test huh and he was like the
most disagreeable person in ten thousand
so he's a rough character he looks like
a pirate I like the sound of him already
yeah yeah well absolutely well
corporations used to hire him to go in
and clean up when things had got messy
so he would start at the bottom of the
company and he said he would ferret out
people who were taking all the credit
when anything went right and then
Distributing all the blame when anything
went wrong and stealing people's ideas
and not doing their job I talked to him
one day I had to deal with some issues
in my lab I had students who were
underperforming and the higher
performing students who were doing their
job were getting demoralized because of
that and so I had to do something about
it and I I really don't like firing
people I I'm not I'm not someone who
likes Conflict at all I tend to I tend
to
I don't like it at all I don't like it
prolonged and I won't engage in the long
run so I tend to settle issues right now
because I don't want it to propagate but
I was talking to my friend about firing
people I said I really can't stand it
how do you manage it because you fired
hundreds of people he said I really like
it
and I thought oh well I've never heard
anyone say that before and he said yeah
I go into these companies and I find
these people who are exploiting everyone
around them and making life miserable
for everyone and trying to gain credit
where no credit is due and being
narcissistic and manipulative and I
ferret them out and I stop them and it's
just fine and I thought good for you and
his career has been very interesting
because he has his own Independent
Business and he's very good at it he's
an engineer but he's moved from
Corporation to Corporation playing this
role and he starts in the lower rungs
and then moves up and then as soon as he
moves up high enough to start to what
would you say threaten
the powers that be who also might be
behaving in a corrupt matter they fire
him and then he has to go do that at a
different place but he's also one of the
people I have around who's
been very useful at let's say calling me
out when necessary and who will
definitely make his opinion known when
it's necessary to make it known and he
does that in search of Excellence you
know and that's the thing that's so cool
about America's Got Talent Britain's Got
Talent Simon said to you that you had to
be right 80 of the time and you said in
order to do that you had to rely on your
authentic judgment and people will
forgive judgment
and see that it's necessary if it's
authentic and not self-serving and I
think those those shows have really
fulfilled the Mandate of bringing hidden
talent to light which is a very noble
cause maybe the most noble cause in some
ways it can also uh you can also have
moments in there where people
you know I can think back to one example
there was a a young lady who did a a
rock violin act where she played
electric violin and danced and sang and
it was all pretty crazy
um very unusual I I like the unusual Pub
I didn't think she was quite ready yet
for Fame and Fortune her name was
Lindsey Stirling and uh I was pretty
mean actually probably unnecessarily and
I said that whilst I found her act
interesting I did think of points she
sounded like I think I said a sack of
rats being strangled right so people on
uh that's a little yeah pretty mean and
everyone's going and she's like a sack
of kittens being stressed yeah exactly
the fact it was rats it made it even
worse um so it it all it was all very
sort of dramatic and it was quarter
final I think and and she left and she
was upset and afterwards a little bit
like maybe I went a bit far blew up on
Twitter and so on but she's now a really
successful act like incredibly
successful touring around and she now
has a tombstone on her stage act with my
face on it
so she never forgot the strangle rights
line and it says R.I.P as Morgan I flash
up a couple of times it gets a huge
Ovation from the crowd they all know the
back story and in a way sometimes you
could see that that it you could be very
mean on people and sometimes in life you
could be mean on people who can't take
it and you might regret it because it
has a negative impact on them when I was
a newspaper editor so I could be pretty
tough pretty ruthless sometimes with
stuff if I felt they're underperforming
but I learned over time there are
certain there are certain types of
people who respond well to criticism uh
even to very tough criticism and there
are certain types of people who just
don't and you've got to work them out
because actually they can all be
talented to some people can take it and
some people can't some people thrive and
fuel off it you know I just played a a
Pro-Am golf tournament called the Alfred
Dunhill links up in Scotland it's
probably that after along with Pebble
Beach in America the most prestigious
Prime you're playing with Professionals
in a four million pound tournament
and for the first two days I've played
the most shocking golf probably seen in
the history of the tournament haven't
played much in the last few months been
working too hard it was all a nightmare
and on the last day I played with a
Belgium professional called Thomas
Peters and he said Pierce how do you
want to play it today how do you want to
get on I said just Sledge me which is
criticize me harshly every time I play a
bad shot I want mockery I want taunting
I want laughter I I want to you to be
all over me like a like a cheap scent so
he did he reveled in his role uh and I
played the best round of my week because
actually what I needed was somebody to
do that rather than somebody politely
going
so when I I when I myself worked for an
editor he was a pretty Infamous
newspaper is it called Kelvin McKenzie
at the Sun
and he said the most annoying trait
about me was that he could give me a
monstering as he called it where he
would scream abuse until his neck's
bulging uh and an hour later I'd bounce
back into his office with a hot story uh
and a smile on my face and he found that
completely annoying because it was not
what he wanted to do he wanted to
trample me down for a few days but he
then said he knew then I would have what
it took to be a newspaper editor and I
do feel in in society we have moved so
far away from that kind of atmosphere
now in workplaces that I do wonder what
about people like me who genuinely
Thrive and get fueled by harsh criticism
is that happening anymore are there any
workplaces left of the world where
anyone is allowed to be exposed to tough
critiques have all talent shows now gone
way too soft do you ever see a really
harsh strangled rats critique which
might fuel the intestine to then go and
be a huge star to prove you wrong in
other words you know I really feel this
that with my old talent show had on I I
things have moved so fast and have gone
so much softer and in my view so much
weaker uh and that's not because I don't
think some people can't take it because
some people can't take it so you've got
to be mindful of them but what about the
vast ways of people who actually Revel
in that kind of atmosphere who Revel in
noise and aggression and passion and
criticism it fuels them inflames them
makes them better people makes them
better at work makes them better perhaps
in their lives I don't know the answer
but I think the pendulum has swung way
too far and we're now becoming such a
saccharine
uninspiring
unpassionate Collective workplace in
particular where the slightest joke told
out of turn leads to you being frog
marched to Human Resources I just feel
like it's gone way the wrong way and the
talent shows actually have moved with
that but everyone on a talent show now
is great even when they're terrible I
scream at them I catch them occasionally
my daughter my daughter loves watching
Britain's Got Talent she's 10.
and she said Dada they're terrible why
are they why the judges all saying that
was great I went because they feel they
have to
It's like because because if they don't
someone's gonna say well you're damaging
my mental health well fine I can respect
I can respect mental illness like come
on you're going on a talent show in
front of millions of people and you want
me to respect your mental health by not
criticizing you if you're not talented
and you go out on the public stage
eventually that's going to catch up with
you and devastate you and so it's better
to have an early warning well speaking
of disagreeable people let's talk about
Donald Trump
oh you've you've known Trump for a very
long time
and you worked with him now did you meet
him for Celebrity Apprentice is that
what and what was that like and tell me
tell me about Mr Trump and let me ask
you some questions if you would so so
you have a very healthy uh experience
with him
so I I met him first on America's Got
Talent he appeared as a guest star I
think introducing one of the shows and I
met him briefly backstage and he was
intrigued by me because he knew that
Rupert Murdoch who was somebody he
greatly admired had made me the youngest
uh newspaper editor for 50 years so he
knew about that part of my background
and that was all he was interested in
really was like that's a rupee one of
rupus guys right so that's how it we had
a sort of a media early connection then
I entered a Celebrity Apprentice which
he was obviously the host of and it was
a pretty fast fascinating experience
looking back because night after night I
ended up winning the show pretty much by
behaving how I thought Trump would want
me to behave so I read the art of the
deal his book about four times before I
went out there and just played it tough
and hard and to win which I knew would
be all traits he would find impossible
to say were not good things
um to the degree actually that when I
won
his last words were peers you're
arrogant you're obnoxious you're
possibly evil but you beat the hell out
of everybody you're my Celebrity
Apprentice when he won the presidency I
send him the same note right right
arrogant you're obnoxious you're
possibly evil but you beat down of
everybody and you're the president of
the United States so we had that little
thing going but on somebody Apprentice
what I remember most vividly was that he
was a very different character in those
boardrooms for three hours a night than
I ever saw when he was president when he
was president he was the ultimate alpha
male I believe playing a role I believe
we didn't see the real Donald Trump we
saw the disagreeable side of him most of
the time the bully boy the the bragard
the you know the the alpha guy who would
never apologize for anything because
it's too weak he was abusive he was
disrespectful and so on in the boardroom
for hour after hour he could be very uh
heartfelt he could be very
um
moved by people he could be very funny
he could be very warm
um I remember all those things and
thinking what happened to that guy
why don't you show the world any of that
stuff because if you did it would be
incredibly disarming so I I won the show
that I then went back into Celebrity
Apprentice each year
as one of his boardroom advisors for a
few years then I joined CNN interviewed
him 30 40 times at CNN
um then he becomes the president of the
United States and suddenly I've got this
guide I've become pretty friendly with
who used to ring me every three or four
weeks for a chat about life and now he's
the most powerful man of the world
um from a loyalty perspective which I
think is a trait overlooked with Trump
I when I uh when he became president I
rang him and I said to him
you know actually first I would say when
I left CNN he was one of only three or
four people in America who bothered to
contact me afterwards and he contacted
me every every month for a few months
how are you doing are you okay can I
help you right now people might say he
had a vested interest in case you pop
back with a big job or maybe but so did
lots of people and he was one of only a
handful of people that bothered to
actually contact me regularly to check I
was okay and could he help I never
forgot that similarly when he won the
presidency I rang him and we had a chat
about a week later
and I I saw one favor of course Chad
because he's always call me Chan because
I wanted to show course champ what is it
I said I just want to have your first
International television interview I
know you're going to do a domestic one
in America but first International done
done and a few months later I was at
Davos in Switzerland a 45 minute
wide-ranging interview with the
president of the United States which was
spectacularly good for my career and he
kept his word so Trump if you were loyal
to him was very very loyal back you know
I followed that with him recently
because I just can't buy into all this
storm election nonsense and I've told
him to his face and he did he just want
to hear it well I think part of the
reason I'm going to lay out some
theories and you tell me if I'm wrong
okay
um I think part of what happened to
Trump was that
that tough
part of him
played well especially the working-class
people and I think that there was an
element of that that was very genuine
especially contrasted with Hillary
Clinton and the Democrats
uh what would you call it patronizing
attitude towards working-class people
Trump could speak to people directly and
he had that bluntness that disarmed them
in some sense and made them believe that
he was at least in in many ways dealing
an honest hand
now he suffered a tremendous amount of
assault through vitriol when he was
running for president and when he was
president probably more than any
president that I can remember including
Richard Nixon who I think might have run
second for having most abuse dumped on
him and whether or not that's deserved
is independent I think in Trump's case
it was it was over the top in quite a
remarkable way and so I think that that
probably
elicited more of that bullying behavior
that might be perhaps a weakness I've
been trying to understand him and the
bullying the last interview you did with
him I believe
one of the things I noted about Trump
was that he would do something about
every 10 minutes that was markedly out
of the ordinary conversationally and so
I watched for that because I'm a
clinician and so I always watch people
talk to see when they're going off
script let's say because there's always
something underneath that and one of the
things Trump does
and I don't know how much of this is
conscious and how much of it is reactive
and how much of it has become habitual
and so say utterly proper uh he'll say
he'll make statements that are
way over the top so I think he said for
example when you were interviewing
something like I tell the truth more
than anyone ever has in history or he's
and then he said about 10 minutes later
something like I've run the best
Administration in American history and
they're over the top Preposterous
statements and they have this
self-aggrandizing element that's got a
juvenile flavor to it and I'm not doing
a global critique of Trump's personality
because I suspect as you've already
indicated that he's a multi-faceted
person but there's an element of him
that's it's he's got this 10 year old
Bully part of him that also has a a
compensatory element and so to say you
know I tell the truth more than anyone
has in history or something along those
lines I think well like who are you
comparing yourself here to exactly like
do you tell the truth more than Jesus
Christ you run a better Administration
than Abraham Lincoln or George
Washington and it's marked because
people don't generally do that in
conversation right they don't come out
with a proposed statement about how
remarkable they are with some degree of
regularity
and now it seems to me to be associated
with some other tendencies that he has
like he has a tendency to nickname
people and he has unerring accuracy in
doing that and it can be devastating and
that also reminds me of someone who's
like a very professional 11 year old
bully and a few of them can bring a
teacher to their knees if their attacks
are targeted and they can certainly do
that with their classmates and so I
wonder with Trump if he's been so he's
pushed into a corner because of all the
vitriol the bullying in braggadocio
tenancy has become exaggerated maybe
he's more surrounded by sycophants now
than might be helpful now I don't know
that for sure but it looks to me like
something that like that is happening
and he's trying to calibrate himself
even during your interview because he
comes out with these statements
something like well look at how
wonderful I am
and I think well maybe if he would have
got credit for some of the things that
he did that were actually pretty
positive like not having America dragged
into a war and like also fostering the
Abraham Accords that he wouldn't be so
inclined to be compensatory in that
manner and then that bullying tendency
seems to be the inverse of that is this
victimization routine which he's
wandered into now Trump claims the
elections were stolen by corruption and
I would say part of the reason people
find that credible is because the
American left-wing establishment and the
liberal establishment for that matter
were unbelievably vitriolic to Trump and
stooped pretty much
do anything in order to devalue and
criticize him no matter how unfair and
how over the top and that generated a
fair Bit of Sympathy on people's part
and I think it generated a sense that he
was in some Global sense treated
unfairly but I I can't see that there's
any legal evidence that's been
compelling that he's been able to bring
forth that the elections were legally
um conducted in an improper and corrupt
Manner and so then what I see happening
with Trump is that he's fallen prey to
the very victimization narrative that he
purports to stand against and so he's
gone off brand it's like well Mr Trump
you're the winner you're the guy who
doesn't have things stolen from him by
by kello fools you're the leader of the
free country you can stand up to the
dictator of North Korea and if Vladimir
Putin himself you're a winner
and that's your brand and yet the
election was stolen from you and now
your story is it was stolen and
everything's corrupt and all the
institutions are corrupt which is
exactly what the left-wing radicals are
saying and there's very little positive
messaging tied up in that and it's
hamstringing the Republicans and so
while that's that's how it looks to me
and so I'm wondering you know Trump very
well I am I not giving the devil his due
in this situation am I often my analysis
in some important way
no I think you're spot on and I think
some interesting points you raised there
and I've always thought Trump is a
unique character and that he has the
thickest skin of anybody I've ever seen
in public life and also the thinnest
skin so he'll react with ridiculous
oversensitivity to every slate and come
out punching but he's able to withstand
the kind of pressure or Scandal that
would engulf and Destroy every other
politician I've ever encountered so he's
a unique hybrid of thick and thick skin
um I think that his his book is very
educational the art of a deal hey it's a
really
entertaining read and actually has a lot
of good business stuff in it so I
recommend people who just want to read
it it's quite fun
um remember he's a real estate tycoon in
Manhattan his whole persona for 50 years
before he became president was to was to
show off embellish and exaggerate
everything every one of his buildings
you can imagine the pitch this is going
to be the greatest Building New York's
ever seen that was in his DNA so it's
perfectly normal for me that he would
take those kind of natural traits to the
presidency and continue to be
self-aggrandizing in the way he was
about his buildings he'd done it for 50
years that's how he squeezed big prices
for his buildings everything was the
best and the greatest ever seen yeah
well that's part of that American
salesman routine right I mean that's
deeply embedded in the American DNA
right he's not the only New York real
estate Tycoon he's like that trust me
I've met a few um but but I also think
that he he also in the book says if
somebody punches as you punch them ten
times harder like that was in his DNA
too Trump has come from a ruffle School
of New York business people where the
only the ones who survive and thrive are
the ones if they get hit metaphorically
or perhaps even physically they hit back
ten times and harder that's always been
Trump's way so if you insult him he'll
come for you hard hard and if you can
survive that well good but many people
including all the candidates in 2016 on
the Republican side they couldn't
withstand their nicknames I mean the
same thing was fascinating to watch him
call Mark Marco Rubio Little Marco and
you suddenly thought wow he's quite
little isn't he low energy Jeb but Jeb
Bush but Bush couldn't work out whether
to be to carry on being himself and
potentially radiate low energy or what
he ended up doing which was being sort
of like a hyper bunny going way too far
the other way to contradict the rumors
of being low energy and he looked
completely insane so Trump was able a
lying Ted about Ted Cruz crooked Hillary
simple tanks they found very hard yeah
he's a brilliant he's a brilliant
marketer he knows how to sell things he
knows how to Market things and he knows
how to do it in a very damaging way to
opponents and he is a you know look he
always said to me people want me to
change because I said why don't you dial
down the Twitter rhetoric a little bit
you know just try to be a little bit
more appealing to to Middle America to
the independence perhaps who are not
like die hard uh Mega fans and he said
why should I dial down anything I've
become the president of the United
States despite being the most under
qualified candidate in history why
should I change
I've just beaten you said the most
qualified candidate the country's ever
seen Hillary Clinton I kept being told I
was the least qualified she was the most
qualified and I've beaten her to the
White House why should I change who I am
and what you're seeing now I totally
agree with you about this with Trump
he's becoming the very thing he hates
most the biggest saurus loser in the
world yeah right and I've tried to and
I've tried to tell him this is just
you've got to leave 2020 nobody cares
everyone's looking forward to 2024 and
if he was able to Pivot you know I think
Trump's real problem oh he's become his
own mimic right just this this problem
that we talked about it to be to begin
with is that people tend to fall into
the the image and then they can't escape
from it
and he loves doing the rallies where he
has tens of thousands of people who you
know buy into his greatest hits of being
what Donald Trump was in 2016. but I I
do think his real problem now is that he
can't let it go he can't let the past go
he can't he's going to relitigate the
2020 election and the I think It
ultimately will cost him any chance of
winning again when in fact if you've
been able to Pivot slightly I think he
would have had a good chance and I'll
give another parallel uh one of the
reasons I fell out with him in the
pandemic period was when he said that
you know from the presidential Podium
that you should use bleach household
bleach to zap the virus out of your body
which is clearly a stupid and dangerous
thing for a president to be saying of
any country let alone the United States
of America when so many people were
dying and he he hated me saying that and
unfollowed me on Twitter which given
only followed 50 accounts was quite a
big deal
um and when he rang me eventually to
sort of seal peace a few months later
just before the election I said to him
do you mind to speak frankly to you said
sure I said look
the thing you've lacked this year and it
may be you just don't have this valve so
be honest with me but you you've lacked
empathy you've lacked empathy over the
pandemic you've made it all about
yourself and the stock market crashing
and made it look like you're taking it
all personally you haven't been
comforter in Chief you don't seem to
have that tool in your Armory you just
want to be the strong commander-in-chief
I said on the George Floyd killing same
thing no real empathy for what a lot of
Americans were feeling and I said that
lack of empathy is going to cost you
because you're up against Joe Biden who
everybody knows from his own personal
tragedies has huge amounts of personal
empathy for people because he lost his
wife and baby daughter in a car crash he
lost his son to a brain tumor and I said
I just think you should show a bit more
empathy and it would go an awful long
way but then I watched him go out the
next day and do some press thing and he
was just exactly the same as normal so
he sort of agreed with me on the call
but then wasn't able to deliver it I
don't think he really has empathy valve
well he's capitalism he capitalized on
well he's capitalized on being
disagreeable which is part of what we've
discussed through this whole show is
that if you're in the public eye like
that and you're a Critic and you want to
say what you have to say and you want to
separate the wheat from the chaff it's
useful to be disagreeable but you can't
be disagreeable all the time one of the
things that happens to be people as they
mature
maybe they start out disagreeable but as
they become more sophisticated they're
able to incorporate agreeable and
compassionate virtues and skills into
their personality and then they can use
them when that's necessary and they can
be disagreeable when necessary and then
you have a personality that's extremely
Broad and capable of dancing with every
situation and so I do see it does look
to me like this is an Achilles heel for
Trump this this tendency to devolve into
a very effective but somewhat juvenile
bullying and an inability well and then
and then combined with that this
proclivity to play the victim which I
really think is stunningly off brand for
him I I can't see that that's going to
be a successful Ploy because it's it
leaves everyone on the conservative side
in the same position that the radicals
on the left want to put conservatives
which is to abandon all Faith In The
credibility of Institutions and then
what do you have
all you have is Blind Faith in the
leader and then of course the leftists
criticized that for being the worst of
populism and in some sense they've got a
point now I think in Trump the leftists
and the Liberals for that matter had a
large hand in creating their own monster
because they chewed on him so hard and
were so utterly I especially saw this
with the Abraham Accords because when
the Abraham Accords which brought a fair
bit of peace to the Middle East for
those of you who are listening who don't
know
um a historic signing of a peace Accord
between Israel and a number of Islamic
States Muslim states uh Morocco and and
among them and Sudan in the United Arab
Emirates and and others with the Saudis
apparently fully on board although not
exactly signing the treaty this happened
when I was ill and I didn't pay much
attention to it but when I recovered and
I saw what had happened in the Abraham
of course it just floored me that this
had received almost no attention and no
credit because it's a really big deal
and so the devil was never given his due
in Trump's situation and I think that
made him a much bigger devil than he
would have otherwise been
yeah I totally agree I think I always
said that I always I wrote about 120
columns for the Daily Mail Us website
about Trump during his presidency and
after he left I worked out about half of
them had been supportive of things he'd
done all said and half of them are
critical and I felt that was a much more
uh accurate take actually on the Trump
presidency a lot of the things he did
albeit delivered often was very blunt
and unappealing rhetoric were were right
you know he was right about a lot of
things he was absolutely has been proven
right about Europe's over-reliance on
Russian energy completely proven right
about that he was right about a lot of
European countries not paying their
proper dues to Nato uh and he was
completely correct to call them out on
that I think he was writing many things
that he did the problem with Trump was
all well he was raped to call out the
sanctimony of the Democrats yes and
there's no doubt he did get treated in a
ridiculously over the top Way by his
opponents there's also no doubt he
fueled that by constantly going into
battle with them my real problem with
trombone the rhetoric was not that he
could be blunt and aggressive it was
when people like Colin Powell or John
McCain died
just Basic Instincts should tell you
if you've got nothing good to say
probably don't say anything
right because these were two American
war heroes regardless of politics and he
came out on both occasions within 24
hours and criticized him in tweets as
they were basically a few hours dead and
I felt that was just unbelievably
graceless and I don't think most
Americans are graceless I just don't
think they are in my experience and I
think I would I would have great it was
a lot of Americans who may have been
tempted to go with Trump's policies but
just thought the guy just how can you do
that it's just not American to do that I
don't think so he lets himself down a
lot actually with stuff like that but
you shouldn't you know I don't think we
should move away from about a lot of his
instinctive gut feeling about policies
were correct and I could see a situation
where someone like DeSantis the the
governor of Florida ends up winning the
Republican ticket
because he basically perceives trumpian
policies but without all the stupid
rhetoric and the silliness and the and
the scandalous stuff which goes with
being Donald Trump and he might well end
up being president a presidency Trump
could have won if he'd look back at his
first four years in office and pivoted
to something more agreeable instead he's
done what you and I said at the start of
this interview he's made the mistake of
going back to what he what he was before
and tried to replicate it yeah yeah well
one of the problems too which is quite
surprising for someone who's as sales
oriented as As Trump and perhaps this is
maybe a sign of exhaustion because it
could be is that he hasn't formulated a
positive Vision it's all it's all
predicated on this idea of corruption
and and theft and as I said that casts
him as a victim which isn't a good look
for him at all or for his supporters it
I've been quite surprised because I've
had a lot of interactions with
conservative politicians in the United
States and Canada and throughout Europe
and it is difficult for conservative
types to generate a positive Vision
because they tend to stand for tradition
and it's not that easy to generate a
compelling forward-looking story when
you're fundamentally reliant on
tradition it can be done but it's very
difficult and but it's sad and upsetting
to see that Trump hasn't been able to
reinvent himself for this next election
and uh I do think that one of the best
possible outcomes might be that DeSantis
can take some of the energy that Trump
generated and move forward in somewhat
the same manner with
less of the juvenile
overlay yeah the key thing I'd say about
DeSantis which I've noticed apart from
the fact his resume is very impressive
this guy went to Yale and Harvard Law
School he was the senior legal counsel
to the commander of Seal Team One in
Fallujah during The Surge which was the
year that America lost most of its
soldiers in in that war he's an
incredibly well qualified guy he also
has a strong personality but he has a
respect for the uh the system he has a
respect for the presidency you know when
when Biden has has had to deal with him
on disasters and things there's a mutual
respect there which I just never saw
with Trump really he would rather shoot
himself than be like that and I think
that he has a respect for the office I
think if DeSantis lost an election he
wouldn't spend the next few years
claiming it had been stolen so I think
that he has a respect for democracy
which Trump doesn't have Trump has a
respect for it as long as he's winning
yeah well so that's a man that's a
example of putting not yourself but the
principles for which you stand forward
and it is necessary if you're a
politician to have due respect for the
institutions and traditions that you
serve because they are larger than you
and if you don't believe that they're
valid although they need to be modified
in the details if you don't believe that
they're valid and they gave rise to you
then there's an eternal contradiction
there that's not trivial and so well
it'll be interesting to see if the
Republicans can negotiate this through
the next election cycle coming up very
very quickly without shooting themselves
in the foot over the Schism in the
Republican side over over Trump so I
guess we should probably bring this to a
close we've been talking for as long as
we're supposed to talk and so it's a
good hand I think on the DeSantis note
and to end with that analysis of of Mr
Trump which I hope was relatively
even-handed and productive I would like
to thank you very much for first of all
the interview that you conducted with me
which I was very
um what was I pleased about it I thought
it went extremely well I I thought I had
an opportunity to say some of the things
that were necessary to say and I enjoyed
very much talking with you and meeting
your sons as well and appreciated the
opportunity that you presented to me and
I appreciated the opportunity to talk a
little bit about the
the so-called in sales you know these
disaffected young men I was talking to
a friend uh uh what would you call it an
associate someone who has knowledge of
Olivia Wilde who had recently made
comments about me being King of the
incels and it's probably worth pointing
out that she married a multi-millionaire
Prince
and so right so she's the she's the
absolute epitome of female hypergamy
that hierogamy that that makes females
very judgmental in their choice as they
should be
but for her to have nothing but contempt
for men who are struggling forward to
try to make themselves attractive to
women is a sign of a
a d of a kind of deep narcissism that on
the female side I would say that deeply
affects our culture and so it was good
to have an opportunity to clear some of
that up you know I've talked to lots of
young men around the world about how
they might make themselves more
attractive on the friendship and career
and dating front and that usually has to
do with telling them that well they have
to subject themselves to that harsh
judgment and if all the women are
rejecting them either because they're
too timid to put themselves forward or
they don't have anything truly to offer
which is something like productive
stable wise judicious generosity in the
highest order why would they expect a
woman to make herself vulnerable
especially on the childbearing
especially on the child bearing front to
them and so if everyone is telling you
that you don't live up to the necessary
standard well then you can demolish the
standards or you can put yourself
together and one of the things that's
been really heartening on that front is
that many of the young men who have been
listening to the ideas I've been
generating and promoting have in fact
put themselves together and they come to
my shows and they're standing up
straight and they're dressed in often a
three-piece suit and now they frequently
have a girlfriend with them and they say
something like you know I decided to
start being authentic and tell the truth
and I decided to adopt some
responsibility and to grow up and all of
a sudden everything's better and the
problems I had are going away and so
that's the solution to the in-cell
problem and demonizing people for being
Lonesome and isolated is not exactly
helpful because it's actually quite a
tough problem to solve so anyways it was
a pleasure meeting you and talking with
you and say hello to your sons
and uh I will they'll be they'll be
thrilled to hear that yeah you can thank
you can thank them on both our behalfs
for their wise counsel
and I've tried very hard again to listen
in this conversation my sister Stanley
in particular be very happy with that
yeah you're taking all the credit well
for two extremely noisy people we
probably listened they're reasonable
amount
exactly well I've thoroughly enjoyed it
well thank you very much pierce it was a
pleasure meeting you
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com